[Musique]
en bordure de seine à quelques centaines
de mètres de la maison de la radio mais
sur la rive gauche dans le 15e
arrondissement se construit l'un des
quartiers du paris de demain la
réalisation de cette oeuvre a été
confiée à la société d'économie mixte
d'équipement et d'aménagement du 15e
arrondissement dans laquelle la ville de
paris est majoritaire de la passerelle
de bir-hakeim au pont mirabeau déjà de
nombreux immeubles ont été démolies il
laisse la place à de nouveaux immeubles
dont certains sont déjà en voie
d'achèvement
comme celui ci le gros oeuvre est
terminé
il dresse ses trente étages dans ce
nouveau chantier et sert de bornes
témoin à ce que sera l'ensemble
dans quelques années les objectifs des
urbanistes et des architectes sont le
modernisme accès facile tout en laissant
une part importante aux espaces verts
ce quartier ainsi transformé prendra
l'aspect d'une cité à l'américaine avec
pour témoin la statue de la liberté
puisque la réplique de l'oeuvre de
bartoli a repris sa place sur le nouveau
pont de relève
[Musique]